[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> It was the end of a very stressful
summer, and I was not at my peak.
I'd been working 60 hour weeks,
I wasn't feeling appreciated at work, and
I said that's it.
I need a vacation.
Can anyone else here relate with that?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Everyone.
The irony was is that I was
in the vacation business.
We need vacations.
They give us better health,
they make us more productive at work.
And studies show that the best ones
are when we go further away from home,
and when we take more time off.
So we should go travelling on vacation.
Problem is,
we don't get a lot of vacation days.
Out of 137 countries
that mandate paid leave,
the United States is not one of them.
The European union requires
20 days of paid vacation.
France and Finland get 30,
Afghanistan gets 35 days of paid leave.
So we should be furious,
we're being deprived of our best days.
There's a sad reality.
We don't even take the vacation
days that are given to us.
In 2014, 41% of Americans
didn't take a single day off.
In that year we left 500 million
days on the table, unused.
I don't get this, I love vacation.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So much, that when I graduated college
I moved to a ski town and I pretty
much made vacation my full-time job.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Maybe people
aren't seeing the value
in vacation that I see.
When I saw study that said that people are
happier when they're planning a vacation
than when they're actually on it,
I knew there was a problem.
To illustrate this,
let's go on a vacation together.
So we start planning.
We look for inspiration, we look at
private beaches, always sunny days.
You see a gorgeous couple
falling madly in love.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In the sunset.
And you think, that could be me.
I just have to go from point a,
boring stressful home or school, and
go to point b, where the land
is magical and everyone's happy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So we start our trip.
Flight was only slightly delayed,
most of your bags made it.
And then you get in the taxi and
you're pretty sure you got ripped off.
Siete means $78, right?
>> [LAUGH]
>> But the hotel pool is just as promised.
You get to your room, though,
and your toilet looks like this.
So you're stressed out.
You sit down in your chair,
you pull out your phone,
and if you're like 70% of people on
vacation, you check your work email.
And that really angers you.
So then you go to Instagram and
you realize, my gosh,
my friends are having a much
better vacation than I am.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You
are now experiencing what we in the travel
industry like to call disappointment.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
this is when your expectations
are much higher than your reality.
I asked my business school friends,
why do you all like to go on vacation?
And the overwhelming response
was that they like to relax.
Why would anyone want to go on vacation,
if that was your reality?
My private equity friend said
that she loves to go on cruises
because she gets to chill out and
do nothing.
My consultant friend echoed this,
and he said that his days are so
hectic that he just likes to
disconnect and do nothing.
There has to be something more
to vacation than nothing.
What I was hearing from my classmates
is that they were treating vacation
as a painkiller to deal with
the psychological stress of their work,
when I could see vacation as
a vitamin to enrich their life.
But how could I convey this
to my consultant friend,
he spoke a foreign language.
So, I made a two by two.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
we decided that the best trips were
both pleasurable and memorable.
And we would plot the data based on
how you would answer the question,
how was your vacation?
So the bottom left quadrant, we've
got the one that we planned together.
It was okay.
And then on the top left, private equity
girl's dream, all-inclusive trip.
You say, aaaah, but
it's not a trip you're going to
tell your kids about in ten years.
Now, the bottom left quadrant,
this is the danger zone.
This is where, hypothetically,
you have to spend the night with
the Russian Federal Police and
then the next day, on the way home,
you get strip searched,
not once, but twice, in Israel.
Don't ask.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The top left,
that must be what we're looking for,
amazing.
As I reflected back on my
own travel experiences,
I realized that the majority
of my trips were amazing.
But some were better than others,
some were more impactful, and
I couldn't put my finger on what that was.
No textbook on the tourism industry
would be complete without a chapter on
Abraham Maslow, a psychologist
who studied motivation in humans.
He created the hierarchy of needs
to say that people inherently seek
self- actualization, when they feel like
they're reaching their full potential.
And along the way,
they must meet certain needs.
And when they do, they're more likely
to have what he calls peak experiences.
He defines these as moments
of the highest happiness,
where people feel like they've
found their place in the world.
I sent these definitions off to
the student body at the GSB, and
I asked them,
have you ever had any peak experiences?
The answers were great.
This is just a snippet.
One of them was from someone who
served in Afghanistan as a pilot.
And after a particularly challenging
mission he said he literally felt
a calming state of nirvana.
This was impactful because, of all the
responses I got, his was the only one that
described a time when he was at work, and
he was serving our country in Afghanistan.
These are the moments that
make life worth living for.
When you feel so much joy and
love and you feel like you've
found your place in this world,
this is exactly what I was looking for
that defined the amazing trips and
the transformational trips.
If we can't find these peak
experiences when we're at work,
when will we, when will you?
Getting the most out of your
vacation takes a lot of practice and
a little bit of knowledge.
And to help you with that,
I created a framework,
Gabby's hierarchy of vacation needs.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And at the base,
at the minimum, you need to disconnect and
take your vacation days.
Next, you need to understand that too
many expectations are setting you up for
disaster because things will go wrong.
And when they do, you want to try and
find a little bit of pleasure in them.
But when the things go right,
you want to make sure that
those are the memorable experiences,
and you remember them.
And when you do, you'll be set up for
peak experiences.
My trips have taken me all over the world,
and so much has gone wrong.
I've lost dozens of passports, literally.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And yes I've been strip search in
Israel, but I've also had
those rare moments of joy and
happiness where I have felt in wonder and
awe of the world.
My hope for you is that you have on-time
departures, and
toilets that you're familiar with.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And that you have many,
many peak experiences along the way.
I hope you enjoy your vacation.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]